join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
next on real america from june 16 1968
california governor ronald reagan
appeared on cbs's face the nation to
take questions from journalists the
future president discusses the 1968
presidential candidates including
richard nixon nelson rockefeller and
george wallace he also discusses
liberalism and conservatism student
protests the recent assassination of
senator robert kennedy and what he
argues are the failures of democrats in
congress and the white house
governor reagan
at the republican governors conference
in tulsa the consensus was that for two
days you conducted yourself like a
candidate for your party's presidential
or vice presidential nomination
do you still maintain you're not a
possible contender for either office
no and i would be hard put to know where
anyone uh got that idea i attended all
of the meetings
uh i don't know of anything i did on the
outside except uh
agree to a press conference uh which was
asked of me
and uh
other than that uh
i was in the meetings where the press
wasn't present or none of the public
in tulsa oklahoma at the republican
governors conference in color face the
nation a spontaneous and unrehearsed
news interview with governor ronald
reagan of california
governor reagan will be questioned by
cbs news correspondent bill stout paul
hope of the washington star and cbs news
correspondent martin legronsky we shall
resume the interview with governor
reagan in a moment
governor i wonder if we can go back to
that question
do you still maintain you're not a
possible contender for either the
presidential or vice presidential office
well i'm certainly not a contender for
the latter for the vice presidential
office i think technically you'd have to
recognize that anyone who is a favorite
son candidate
even though he is a favorite son
candidate only in the
the sense of
directing a delegation or hoping to
that technically
at the convention he is a candidate he
has entered in nomination
and would be a candidate if the party
chose to consider him as such well now
really you're more than technically a
candidate aren't you
well
you mean at the convention i mean now at
the convention
anytime
well i certainly am not now i have
uh i haven't injected myself into this
race nor would i but at the convention
as i say i use the word technically
because it is true that you actually are
placed in nomination that's true of me
as well as a number of other favorite
sun candidates
and uh
i have said for some time that i believe
this is going to be an open convention
and therefore if the delegates
choose to consider other than the
announced candidates they'll do so
when you say that you haven't conducted
yourself here governor as a possible
contender
you're talking perhaps about your own
attitude but what do you think of the
attitudes of the people the people and
the delegates decide who will run
you don't really decide for yourself and
no man going into a convention does bill
i've said this for a long time i think
the people do
this job seeks
rather than someone seeking it
and
this you have very little control over
i i'm aware of a great many people who
have expressed this
belief with regard to me
and i'm greatly honored as i've said
before that anyone should consider me in
that in that light
but i can again say that i have
been doing my job and i have done
nothing to encourage or to try and set
up any organization to to promote that
sort of thing
let's carry you you carried yourself a
step further at least now we have you
saying you're not considering yourself
as a contender for the vice presidential
nomination but you can't help it if you
go as a favorite son which makes you
contender for the presidential
nomination
now could you address yourself to this
which candidate of the two men who do
say they want to be president
get the presidential nomination on the
republican ticket nixon or rockefeller
with which of those two could you most
easily make common cause
well now
now i have to not only be evasive i just
have to avoid the answer because
i have asked our own delegation we have
only had one organizing meeting
so far and that was prior to the uh
official placing them on the ballot or
getting them
recognized on the ballot as the
delegation
i've asked all of our delegates to not
give any opinion as to who
they might favor
when if the time comes to to make a move
in some direction
in order to ensure the very unity that
caused us to have a single delegation to
begin with
now it hardly behooved me now to come on
television nationwide and announce a
preference of my own i just can't do it
well as governor of the largest state in
the union don't you feel some obligation
to to to lead the people oh yeah
who you're for
no we
we ran on the basis of a broad-based
delegation
in which if we were for someone in
advance we would have sought a
delegation of people who were pledged or
who leaned in that same direction we
didn't in the interest of unity which
was the whole purpose of this
we have a delegation from california
that represents the whole spectrum of
the california party we have people who
are actively in support of various
candidates on that delegation and who
have had past support for those
delegates now
the idea of not having an open primary
in the interest of unity was
so that at the convention
when all the facts are in and it is time
to make a decision for who we think will
be the winner and the next president of
the united states to say nothing of of
platform decisions
that hopefully our delegation can
resolve its differences within itself
and operate as a unit for the best
interest not only
aren't you really
aren't you really playing it a little
cozy expecting that something
something's going to develop for you at
the convention
no i don't think so
as a matter of fact the only thing i can
give you by way of
proof of sincerity is and bill being a
californian knows this
that i was the one who was opposed to a
favorite sun candidacy
and
this was announced the day after i was
elected at a joint press conference with
bob finch the lieutenant governor and
bob publicly stated then he was going to
do everything he could to convince me i
should be one in the interest of unity
and the result was the party leaders and
our state central uh committee officers
were the ones who persuaded me that i
should be the favorite sun candidate
governor let's can we can we get one
thing
perhaps you could tell us
would you say your political philosophy
was closer to that of mr nixon or mr
rockefeller
well i think without my answering that
you could probably say that to me no why
should i answer the question well
because i think that on the basis of
views expressed for example right now in
the vietnam conflict or on the the
approach of uh
or the involvement of government in the
solution of some problems uh yes i would
think that this uh that this would be a
fair statement what would be the first
that
that i have perhaps uh
tended to
towards solutions of national problems
more in the same context or vein that
richard nixon has than i have at times
with the well governor rockefeller let's
take this a step further governor when
we talk about the convention and the
delegates there are estimates ranging
from i've heard 38 percent i've heard 60
percent
of goldwater delegates and alternates
returning this year to miami
do you see yourself
as the only hope of the conservatives in
the party they certainly are not going
to rally around nelson rockefeller and
many of them may not around richard
nixon where else do they have to go
except you
well bill i i'd
as you know won't go along anymore with
with using those labels i've been
working for two years trying to get the
party to drop the labels but a great
many people do use them and yet we've
been very successful though with getting
them to i think there is a different
philosophy or belief in the republican
party today at the grassroots level and
on up through the pros
i think you will find the republican
party today is far more
willing
to
see good in uh in other republicans in
the interest of unity and in the
interest of winning
uh there is a great desire we've had our
bloodbath and learned a lesson from it
now the party was virtually out of
existence
just a few years ago
and i don't think that you're going to
uh to have that problem i don't think
people are going to this convention
frozen into an ideological mold
uh as they have been at some time
governor let's not talk about being
frozen um you do say that your political
philosophy comes closer to that of mr
nixon and to mr rockefeller i mean that
is one position you have taken now
now the nixon coordinator in the south
mr callaway
recently said perhaps we can get george
wallace
on our side that's where he belongs
would you feel that
george wallace belongs on the republican
side and would you welcome him in the
republican party
well
i think this is the decision if george
wallace belongs on the republican side
then he should register
but he is still registered as a democrat
and it would seem to me that um
anyone
i've always believed that anyone who
wants to come into the republican party
has come in by virtue of buying our
philosophy
but we don't go out after someone by
virtue of buying theirs
and therefore if he found that he was
compatible and could believe in the
philosophy of the republican party then
i would think that his place was in our
party
under those circumstances under the
circumstances that he subscribed to our
philosophy what do you think he's
compatible with your philosophy
well i think if you look at his record
as a governor you will find a number of
instances where on domestic issues
he has been
right in line with the present
democratic philosophy of of government
control and subsidy and regulation and
so forth which would be contrary
to republican philosophy at the moment
no question that he's expressed some
views particularly in the international
scene regarding americanism and
patriotism and so forth that i'm sure a
few people uh disagree with what about
his position on racist problems well
he seems to have avoided that subject
pretty well i haven't uh heard too many
statements without that i've heard
everything he says or even paid too much
attention to what it but i haven't heard
uh that much has been said that he's
well is what i mean against integration
to make a specific point
well i happen to be one who believes in
first of all i'm i am incapable of
feeling prejudice myself
i do not believe in discrimination
and i
certainly believe in equality of
opportunity for all people
and i believe that the answer to the
problem will come
someday when
all of us in america will stop using
just as we've stopped using the labels
in our party we'll stop hyphenating
ourselves and using a word in front of
american without with a hyphen let's
let's go back to these labels governor
that you object to but most people in
this country
employ in common talk
liberal and conservative
senator kiekel lost to max rafferty and
there doesn't seem much argument
within the republican party that kiko
represented the moderate or liberal wing
and rafferty the conservative perhaps
the right wing what do you make of that
well i recall
during the campaign hearing both of them
comparing
one the contender comparing his views
and the other comparing his vote record
with the voting record of senator george
murphy
and
they came out about even
with the support of the things that
george murphy had stood for
now
i think the the kiko rafferty campaign
there are a lot number of factors first
of all the contender in this case
has been a very successful campaigner in
california winner of two elections by
wide margins one
by a very wide margin
he is known to the people of california
and the other
didn't uh
campaign as actively
uh
spending a great deal of his time in
washington because the senate was in
session
and i think that's uh that max rafferty
himself gave a view that cannot be
discounted too much
he said that he believed there is such
dissatisfaction on the part of the
people today
with what's been going on
that there is a kind of tendency against
the incumbent instead of the other way
around not just not just a swing to the
right but against individual incumbents
that's right there's a sort of uh let's
have a change well how much did party
loyalty play in in the kiko rafferty
race uh kiko did not support you he
didn't support nixon he didn't support
george murphy was that a major factor
well there you'd have to ask the people
who voted and why they voted i would
have
do you think it was a factor
i honestly don't know it was a hard
fought campaign they criticized each
other but i think there was a basically
adherence to our 11th commandment there
was no uh
they didn't inject personalities and get
into that kind of bitterness at all well
rockefeller didn't support uh barry
goldwater in 1964 do you think this
should be a factor in his candidacy this
year is he entitled to the nomination
not having supported the nominee in 64.
i'm opposed to anything
that is going to
reopen old wounds or that is going to
lessen our chances for making a change i
think it is vitally important
in america today that we have a change i
think the present democratic leadership
has taken this country or lack of
leadership actually has taken this
country down a road
that can lead only to disaster and ruin
for the country and
i think the issue is far more important
than dredging up or remembering
any past
grudge but republicans have to nominate
a nominee
if the people
do not know
where the republicans stand if they
don't talk about one another how are
they supposed to decide
well in california 1966 we waged a
primary in which we campaigned our views
and what we would do as opposed to those
of the incumbent democratic
administration and the people made the
decision on who they thought would be
the best replacement for that
administration this does not mean that
you take on the other you state your
case you run against the opposition you
know this is a tryout
for who's going to run in the big race
against the other school and i've
likened it to a
track meet if on wednesday afternoon the
kids go out on the track to do a hundred
yards to determine who's gonna run on
saturday against the other school in the
big track meet
you've tried to find out who's the
fastest you don't go down the track
spiking each other
to see who can be the only survivor yeah
but that's a different game governor
that's not politics no i don't think
it's a different game what are we
interested in we are interested in the
views of the republican candidates
and what they would offer and what they
would propose
in contrast
to the leadership that we now have in
washington
and
thus there's no need
to point a finger at any other
republican candidate you state your case
what you would
it's always happened in every campaign
particularly in primaries and i'm sure
it happened in the 66 primary between
you and george christopher well
no i would ask you to go back and find
one
word that i ever said about him
but it takes two you know he said a
great many things well um
uh
whether that had anything to do with the
result or not um
people made a decision governor would
you say there's a fundamental difference
between your position on vietnam and
that of nelson rockefeller
i can't say that i'm a complete
authority on his position i used this
just as an example a moment ago and
incidentally let me correct one
if i gave an impression there
that this meant that i was supposed to
be favoring one over the other no you
asked a question i honestly tried to
answer it but at the same time
in governor's conferences
governor rockefeller and i have been in
great agreement on many times across the
table on issues that were confronting us
the
i know that he is is
has announced
whether he has stated it already or not
a position or that he's going to explain
a position on vietnam but it has been my
when i said there was a that i perhaps
was closer on that one used looking for
an example
i think that what i was actually trying
to say was that both richard nixon and i
have over the period of the past year
spoken out against the limited war
concept
against a win policy and against the
need to be there
now
and against the need to be there you
mean you're willing to lose against the
no no no against did i say win against
the no no the no win policy
uh
it's been my impression that uh
perhaps nelson is placing a
little more faith in the negotiations
or in some kind of compromise settlement
than i find myself able to you have no
faith in that prospect of paris oh i i
can hope for peace
but i don't hope for the kind of peace
that would result in say
a concession that would allow the viet
cong to be a a part of the
south vietnamese government i think this
would be about the same as the united
states government taking the casa nostra
in his partners governor if we can if we
can move to a different topic
the day after senator kennedy died or
perhaps it was the day he died
you blamed demagogic and irresponsible
leaders in and out of office you said
that their words had fed this attitude
of lawlessness in our society
and as i recall after that news
conference in sacramento you refuse to
identify any of them or you fail to
identify them can you tell us now what
kind of people do you have in mind what
what are their names well bill let me
straight one thing out i didn't say
demagogic leaders i said demagogic
statements by people in and out of
public office
now a demagogic statement can be
deliberate it can also simply be
carelessness on the part of the
individual who
didn't intend to be a demagogue but
you can go back one of the reasons for
not naming an individual
is to try and pick out and name one
would be unfair unless you were going to
compile a list of all of them and their
statements and say here all of these
statements we think have contributed to
this atmosphere but we have had
statements first specifically
do you have senator did you have senator
robert kennedy's statements in mind his
own statement i can only tell you that
robert kennedy in the last several weeks
in california
has actually been campaigning
on a basis of
healing the wounds restoring law and
order stopping the violence in our
countries
i was talking about i wasn't talking
about individuals i was talking about
statements and i would repeat and
practice some of those statements all
right some of them might have been
attributed to him but statements such as
someone saying that if he lived in a
slum he too would join a rebellion or
could not you would you're pretty right
is that what you're talking about uh
this is the kind of statement i'm
talking about i'm talking about
statements made several years ago of a
statement that perhaps a jail record
would be a mark of honor
in this country
with regard to being arrested for
demonstrations and so forth i'm talking
about any statement of the kind that
encourages riots now these could
encompass a great many commencement
speakers of the last week or so who have
appeared on a number of campuses and
they come from a number of lines of
activity including academic including
the judicial
and public figures who have talked about
encouraging
uh supposedly
just dissent but encouraging the the
type of rioting that we've seen in our
campuses i claim these statements are
demagogic and i claim it's time
for anyone who is going to speak
publicly
to think twice with regard to his words
and any word that he thinks might be
used
even misinterpreted by someone as to be
a ticket
or an admission for him to go out and
take the law into his own hands we'd
better think twice governor you've
talked about student protests where
would you draw the line
on student protests on our campuses
what we have in this country
a built-in system for dissent this is
what we mean by freedom of speech
freedom of assembly
we have a right to try and persuade our
fellow citizens to try and persuade our
elected officials
but i think that dissent
must stop short of interfering with the
rights of other individuals when a group
takes over the administration building
and other buildings of a campus
when they interfere with the orderly
processes of the administration when
they force the cancellation of classes
and studies on the part of the majority
who happens to disagree with them when
they when they attempt by force
to prevent recruiters from various
industrial firms from coming on a campus
seeking future employees
when they go out in the street and stage
civil disobedience it's all well and
good to say that they're staging the
civil disobedience with an idea that uh
that they will pay the price by being
arrested
but how do they repay the person who
might have been in an ambulance on their
way to the hospital who was blocked and
held up by this demonstration in the
street how do they repay the person
perhaps whose house burned down because
the fire department couldn't get through
the thousands of people let us say in
one of our california cities who were
attempting to attack a draft center
civil disobedience
in taking the law into your own hands
you very rarely if at all can do this
without interfering with the basic
rights of someone else and with this we
have no right to do you think the
president should have let the poor
people's campaign
camp on public lands in washington
no i don't
unless they were ground suitable for
camping unless they were coming into an
area where this was
the custom and where this was was proper
uh frankly
i am in disagreement with this
particular march
and i'm disagreement with the
govern government's acceptance of it
on the basis not of disagreeing with the
goals i think all of us want to do
everything we can to to lift the
standard of living to bring everyone up
as as high as they can be brought to
enjoy the things that this society of
ours can afford
but i think there is a a great
disillusionment coming to many people
first of all the idea that by coming and
staging such a demonstration in
washington they can persuade the
congress to pass some law that's going
to eliminate poverty or alleviate it
even
is a falsehood and many people were are
deluded into believing that this can
take place there's nothing wrong with
the american people or the american
government's attitude toward proper of
poverty our record proves we have spent
billions of dollars in hundreds of
programs in a legitimate effort to try
and find an answer to these problems but
the truth is it is the manner in which
we've done it that has failed there's no
lack of intent they don't have to
persuade congress to to feel a sympathy
for the poor we already have that
governor they are poor they feel that
the remedy is not in sight immediately
for them and they sought this way
apparently to dramatize their position
this was with under the aegis really of
the right of a public demonstration the
effort of people to seek redress from
the congress itself but you would
disagree with the president having
permitted them to take the position that
they did in the shadow as it were of the
lincoln memorial yes because
again i must say i think that a great
many people are going to be
disillusioned that were deluded into
believing
that this could result in some immediate
answer to their problem now again you
get back to dissent and what is needed
in this country
there are great many voices have been
heard one of them was the late senator
robert kennedy's
saying virtually the same things that
i've been saying in california as a
matter of fact in california he was
advocating what we are doing in
california a program to provide jobs to
the poor to the minority
element and the
here in other words was a place
proper leaders of the poor should be
telling them
support those people today who are
advocating a change in the programs that
are a failure but governor even before
the horror of the ambassador hotel
robert kennedy also spoke for tougher
gun control laws and you have said we
probably have the best laws in the
nation in california now we do
you think we generally yes we do
gentlemen i really regret our time is up
thank you very much governor reagan for
being here to face the nation
a word about next week's guest in a
moment
today on face the nation governor ronald
reagan of california was interviewed by
cbs news correspondent bill stout paul
hope of the washington star cbs news
correspondent martin negronski led the
questioning
next week senator thomas dodd of
connecticut leader in the fight for a
strong gun control bill
and harold glassen president of the
national rifle association which is
fighting additional gun control
legislation will
face the nation
up next on real america we continue our
look back at the 1960